hello everybody and welcome to episode
number four of my random items flipping
series I know I haven't done one of
these in like two months as for those of
you who are new basically what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
flipping five random items and we're
going to get those via a random number
generator so basically just a dice roll
between 1 and 4,000 that will correspond
with a sellable item in the RuneScape
database and we're going to start with 1
mil and do five flips so on top of that
uh because so many of the items are bad
we will have two skips available one
skip is just going to be a no hassle
skip just roll get a new item the second
skip is going to be a User submitted
item and that is going to take place of
the item I rolled and now once I use
that I'm stuck with the item no matter
what so about 40 or 50 suggestions were
left on the last video which was 2
months old to be fair uh but if you guys
want to leave a suggestion for the next
video it'll actually enter you in a draw
uh for 1 mil assuming you are subscribed
to my channel so make sure you're
subscribed leave a comment for an item
that you think would be fun bad doesn't
matter what it is uh in the comment
section and uh you could win the 1 mil
all right guys let's get started all
right so we have uh 1 mil in our
inventory let's get started with the
first
flip so we're going to start by getting
a random number so it's between 1 and
3,246 uh which you can see here I have
on a spreadsheet these are all sellable
items and yeah let's head generate and
see what we get
751 that is going to
be a fruit blast feel like I've actually
done this item before but let's have a
look in G tracker what we're looking at
Here Fruit blast 2200 2200 so might
actually do pad uh de 2,000 traded a day
definitely going to do the fruit blast
no idea what the limit is on this but
yep we're just going to go
ahead do it fruit
blast pretty sure this is a quest item
so this might not be too awful 2200 is
what we can buy it
for and we sold it for 500 so yeah that
is a pretty good uh margin actually
let's have a look at what price yeah it
looks like there's usually a pretty big
margin in this
item um let's go look over here 100,000
wow that sucks that's kind of funny
though uh go down to the wheat cuz it's
kind of weird that just skews the whole
thing but anyway it's around 2,000 it
seems like so we'll definitely go ahead
and buy fruit
blast 510 and now see how many can Mo
forward
here I do 1900 I don't think I would get
anywhere close to this but if we leave
it in long enough maybe we'll actually
hit it all right guys we'll come back
when this item has sold okay guys so we
did eventually sell the fruit blasts uh
we left them in for quite a while though
we left them in for like 3 days uh but
we got, 1500 GP and profit on each one
giving us 103k in profit uh which is
really good for that kind of item
imagine if I just left that in for like
a month who knows I could have made a
mill in profit off this just the fruit
blast uh so we'll go ahead and get our
second item going here and we get
1680 uh so we'll go have a look at what
that corresponds to looks like it's
going to be the skull shell Splinter now
I have never heard of this item before
so it's probably not a very good sign
for its trade volume uh but we'll look
at it anyway okay uh it doesn't seem too
bad there's still 20 or 30 traded a day
I think actually a little more this
might actually be a good item we'll just
have to check what the margin is looking
like and nothing okay so that is more of
an issue than anything doesn't seem to
be any type of margin on it uh so in
that case I think we're going to go
ahead and skip this item and just grab a
new one mainly just because there is
zero margin on
it all right so we're going to use our
first skip here just no hassle free uh
Skip and we'll get our next item
622 this seems kind of nerdy but I'm
almost positive that's Amulet of
Glory it is so the am of Glory uncharged
definitely go ahead and do the am of
Glory because it's very highly traded
item uh all right margin on them usually
okay so we're going to buy it
for
2810 and we'll sell it
for 2620 so 200 GP margin not awful not
really great but we'll go aead ahead and
uh can afford like 50 of these or
something and then we'll come back when
they have sold okay guys we are back um
the am of glories did not take too long
to sell uh probably only like an hour
and we flipped uh pretty much all of
them that we wanted claim that that is
going to
be it's a 10K profit it's not awful
actually hit that random button
2574 that is going to be ooh
combat mix
one that is very obscure and not very
expensive
unfortunately um okay so I just read
this message here the last known values
from two months ago are being displayed
so we 100% have to get rid of this item
unfortunately uh but we do have the
wheel loaded up here now these are
suggestions from a couple months ago uh
again if you did submit this and are
still watching I know it has been a
while um if your suggestion comes up you
will earn the 1 mil and uh for next week
again leave your suggestions awesome to
see you guys with some good ideas or bad
ideas sometimes depending on what the
item is but anyway let's spin see what
we
get red spider eggs um so if that was
your suggestion I'll put a uh text in
the video you've just won 1 mil and yeah
let's go have a look at red spider eggs
all right red spider eggs pretty highly
traded item should be good I've actually
never tried flipping these before
though and yeah let's
go red spider
eggs H we bought them for 71 and we're
going to sell them
for 67 so that is a 4gp margin pretty
[Music]
good and uh how many can we
do can't imagine the buying limits
higher than that supp put in 10k and I
will come back when they have flipped
okay we are back and uh the red spider
eggs did sell for a 1 GP margin only uh
that being said we did do all 10,000 uh
so might even have a bigger bu limit in
this still bit unsure about that uh but
I'll claim it and that will be 10K in
profit not too bad not that great let's
get a new item though all right we're
generating our fourth item here it's
going to be 11 18 two which is going to
be runee boots uh that's pretty good
we'll go ahead and quickly look that up
ah what's the point of it anyway we have
to do it all right we bought it for
$81.99
and we sold it for 7611 so pretty
decent uh limit for this I think is
[Music]
70 and there we go we'll come back when
they have sold all right guys the room
boots have sold we got the full Bine
limit worth and we sold them for a
pretty decent profit actually uh sold
them for 8198 each and we bought them
for 7612 giving us 40K in profit so
really not too bad we're up to 16k in
profit so far now on to our last
item let's hope we don't get something
bad cuz we are stuck with it no matter
what generate and we are going to get 26
[Music]
48 this could be almost
anything keep scrolling and it is odium
Shard
one that's funny all right let's do The
odium Shard
one okay selling quantity buying
quantity
says it has a 2K margin on G
tracker and how many Trad did I day for
this one not too
bad and uh looks like we can maybe snag
it for really cheap but uh I don't think
we're going to wait that
long plop it in maybe
for 85 in a bit K
see odard one
correct and I will do 10 how about I
might be pushing a bit anyway all right
we'll come back when this has sold all
right guys we are back and The odium
Shard one worked quite well uh we sold
it for 101k each uh which is going to
leave us with let's have a look
here 160k in profit that was a very good
item actually flipped pretty quickly as
well and yeah that's it guys we ended
the episode with
315k in Profit just goes a show that you
can flip nearly anything there aren't
really any bad items just bad prices
you're going to pay for them and once
again guys if you want to be involved in
the next episode uh leave a comment down
below with a item that could be put onto
the random wheel uh that would flip uh
as a replacement for a shitty item so I
hope you guys enjoyed and I will see you
guys in the next
episode o
[Music]